this is a story you'll only see on eight  news now the i-team  is following another federal  investigation into the post office  after a cyclist found a stash of mail-in  ballots on the side of the road  it was a concern and it was also a  little bit confusing too like it was  it was mailing ballots it wasn't any  other kind of mail  so this happened up in the northwest  valley near lone mountain  there were no letters or flyers just 10  ballots with addresses about  two miles away inspectors with the  postal service say someone may have  taken those from a neighborhood delivery  box  and it's likely the thief was looking  for checks or credit cards  and just toss the rest john